do you see yourselves taking more wives
Boozman drops a bomb and it's honest
commentary continues part two of before
the 90-day season for too long and
stirred a lot of our burning questions
and it also had us side-eyeing time did
you ask
Avery out on a date yes it's an
attractive woman Bob did you also ask
Stephanie out
yeah but she's hard I would like to go
out with Steph welcome my 90 day fans
fam it's Melissa here let's go ahead and
get into the must-see moments from
Vitello now coming in at number one
Guzman said that he is going to take on
another wife if Lisa can't give him a
child literally all of us in that moment
the chances of Osmonds taking on another
way it's 99% women over 50 years old
have a 1% chance of having a healthy
natural conception 1% it happens but
it's very rare and of course science has
evolved but that's pretty expensive so I
think Osmond knows what he's doing
I'm not sure if lisa has wrapped her
head around the fact that Huisman is
serious about this and my next thought
is what is his new wife gonna do I mean
to have to deal with Lisa she's a minute
that she's a lot she's gonna run hour
away it seems as if all Lisa is
concerned about is being the first wife
and how the marriage is viewed in
America yes it would be illegal for OHS
men to have a second wife here in the
state
but he doesn't live in the States and
where he lives
it's totally legal so I'm not sure if
lisa has really wrapped her head around
that yet but I will say this I'm gonna
miss this couple I really enjoyed their
storyline and I hope TLC 90-day fiance
brings them back in some sort of way
baby girl our bad for you anything you
want I will do it for you girl
yes thanks man thanks for that Bob all
right something else that it's pretty
hard to wrap your head around David said
he and Lana are not together but still
engaged Lana is not very communicative
with what telling me like what's
happening what's going on but you're
engaged to her I guess I just want to
talk to David I just want to have a
one-on-one with David I really want to
understand where his mind is in this
moment he's essentially been chasing not
he's been chasing Lana for seven years
try to visit her four times she didn't
show up on the fifth she finally showed
up but then made all of these excuses
about spending time with him these are
all the signs that someone is not
interested in you and I'm just not sure
why David has not accepted that yet
during the tell-all I learned something
that I didn't even know existed and it
made me wonder if David really is just
into the chase maybe he just likes the
chase when he started talking about the
catalogs that he had in the 90s and how
he would flip the pages and pick which
girl you wanted to ask to go to the
social and Ukraine and if they were
interested they will show up when he
would arrive there that blew my mind
because I didn't even know this was a
thing and then comes Caesar
we all remember Caesars relationship
with Maria it was a lot but come to find
out Maria and David actually talked
before as well isn't that crazy how
small is the world
well how smaller these dating sites they
actually exchanged conversation and
following that information
field we learned that David has talked
to about a thousand people on these
sites him and Cesar started doing this
back and forth about yeah I talked to
1210 David said oh I talked to a
thousand so at that point I just had to
say okay my heart is breaking for David
but maybe I should just accept the fact
that he might enjoy this he might love
the chase this may be a game that he
enjoys I don't know I've tried to wrap
my head around it it's something hard
it's very hard to digest something else
that is hard to digest it's Tom Tom Tom
Tom Tom what are you doing to my girl
Darcy all right so after claiming that
he was just being pleasant by asking
Avery to go out on a date
Tom reveals who he really wants it takes
a dinner table did you also ask
Stephanie out yeah but she's hot I would
like to go out with stuff Tom Tom you
can't do that that's not cool she's hot
that's not cool
of course you can access any to go out
on a date but don't do it in front of
Darcy's face sometimes I wonder if Tom
really is just trying to get under Darcy
skin and she's just sitting there with
that poker face trying to mask her
emotions and deep down inside you can
tell she she was hurt that were my
feelings my ex is sitting here acting my
castmates to go out on a date and then
ACTA I don't want to go out and date on
a date too and then he says he didn't
buddy we know he dated oh that's a hard
pill to swallow that's a hard pill to
swallow it's bittersweet
that you know the seasons coming to an
end but lucky for us we have some new
faces and stories to get into 90-day
fiance the other way season 2 is finally
here so make sure you stick with ET as
we follow these new couples in their
journey to take their love to the next
level alright see you next time
[Music]